all right I'll tell you've been hearing
political analysis of what people think
will happen during tonight's debate but
I'm going to do it a little differently
joining me now actor and comedian Rob
Schneider one of our favorites hosts of
Woke Up in America on Fox Nation Rob
great to see you tonight what do you
think with your political experience and
acumen
I thought it was going to stand out
tonight
I think I'm looking at Vivek to have
another
um to be attacked by Chris Christie and
and by the way no matter what Vivek
ramaswamy uh whatever he accomplishes it
doesn't matter because just what he has
done for the American East Indians with
unpronounceable names is really a
astounding and I'm very proud of that
for him uh let me see it's nice to know
that Nikki Haley can be just as much of
a warmonger as the other Gentleman on
the stage and Chris Christie let's be
honest uh he doesn't have a chance but
he's still there it's nice you know
Chris Christie's a guy no matter how
heavy you get as an American it's a good
reminder that just wait three four
minutes and you'll see somebody
way heavier than you
and you'll feel better oh my gosh Rob
Rob look really going below the belt
here
and above the belt I
am manager made her own prediction and I
don't even know her name by the way that
tells you a lot about her campaign
manager or me about what we're going to
see tonight at the debate stage check
this out
stream kind of positions and and
policies that we'll hear likely tomorrow
night just coming from the debate stage
right over the hill you know as we
continue to see those extreme policies
we stand here rooted in the values that
we know continue to ensure that we are
growing our economy
Administration is rooted in but she
doesn't even seem to believe that I mean
you're watching her body language listen
does she seem like she's really on board
the Biden train or whatever we're
calling it Caboose so fine I think it
spoke Val it spoke volumes the four
supporters she was able to get at that
press conference I think that some of
the values the values that these that
the byte Administration uh you know
wants to make sure uh like what stoves
we use what kind of cars we drive and
what air conditioners we're allowed to
have in our homes these are the values
of the Biden Administration and I I
think it should be a pretty much a slam
dunk you know it's um it's incredible
like for me to see the defense for the
Democrats is like yes Joe Biden's son
did take advantage of his father's
position and but Joe had didn't make any
money I I didn't make any money off it
now that's your defense that's an
admission of guilt how is this still all
Happening Now Rob what what's amazing
about this is well you're from from the
field of Comedy obviously in acting now
if this had been a republican who had as
many gaffes and as many physical
stumbles and Senior moments as Joe Biden
has had I mean this would be 24 7 on all
the comedy sides obviously SNL but but
with Biden it's kind of oh shucks ain't
that cute or Ah that's just Joe but I
mean it's ridiculous it's almost as if
95 of the media is in the hands of the
illiberal liberal Intelligentsia and
there's nothing we can do about it no
they're gonna the thing is about it it's
like they're wrongs and their evil is
going to be way way not as bad as ours
as the as the conservatives and they're
just going to run with it and so
unfortunately you really do have
um like I said before I mean people in
California would vote for an avocado if
next to it and there's just a tribalism
that I think people are waking up to I
want you to moderate the next debate or
the next debate or there one of them
I'll pay to see that I'll co-moderate
with you rob great to see you as always
thanks so much thank you Laura hey Sean
Hannity here hey click here to subscribe
to Fox News YouTube page and catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis you will not get it anywhere
else